hello sir I am officer Lo Angus stops
being audio and video recorded again I
know I think you know why I stopped you
you ran the red light what actually
happened was I was stuck in the middle
of the intersection yeah I was behind
you the whole time yeah yeah so
technically we're not supposed to enter
the intersection at all for that reason
because if the light turns red then
you're stuck in the intersection then
you run the red light so that's the
reason I stopped you do you have your
license on you
thank you do you have the registration
and insurance
we just got this for you out you know
what I'm just gonna get this out for you
okay
so can you would you
explain that to me a little bit further
so in Pennsylvania when you're stuck
with
actually you have to make the left so
what would what would the appropriate
thing for me to
have done just
you're not supposed to block an
intersection like that in Washington so
just by you blocking the intersection
that's technically a ticketable
violation and then thus then you're
running a red light so it's another
ticketable offense so you're not
supposed to proceed into the
intersection until you can go because a
lot of people do what you just did right
is like you're sitting in the
intersection waiting and then turns and
you're blocking so yeah there was a
little bit of confusion
I wasn't sure what they were doing and
then they put on their light to turn so
I thought that maybe they were letting
me go through oh did you see that no
like right before I made the turn there
was someone who
they write they didn't have their
you know their signal on so I wasn't
sure if they were just waiting yeah so I
just advise
uh just don't enter the intersection
until you can go so you don't get stuck
um
see
but in that situation the best thing to
do then would be back on
and not
I don't know if there's a best thing to
do in that situation because you're
either going to back up into somebody
yeah or you're going to run a red light
so or you're going to be sitting in an
intersection there's not really a great
option there yeah I was just slightly
into the cross
yeah yeah we're on
Mania we actually don't have like
crosswalks oh so even if you're if
you're kind of slightly
they have there's a little bit more
leeway as well like there are a few
lines like there's one white line and
there's another one there's like a like
a certain margin from which you can
actually kind of put your place your
vehicle
um yeah yeah so I know it lost very
state to state but there is a law in
Washington for blocking an intersection
like that proceeding through and you
know um when you're just stalling I
forget the actual verbage I can find it
for you but it's like stalling blocking
an intersection I'm just curious about
the law I don't mean to oh no yeah I can
find it for you yeah
um one second
that looks good
on I don't see Pennsylvania registration
like at all okay let's see expires
November 22nd or 2022 okay
and yeah yeah
yeah okay that looks good I'll hand that
back to you I'm just gonna go check your
info I'll try to find that uh RCW the
law for you and I'll be right back
all right
Sierra 331 Code 4 driver
last of Co Burger King ocean Henry boy
Edward Robert George Edward Robert
versus Brian boy Robert Young Adam Nora
middle C Charles date of birth one one
two one nine four Mount Washington
331 theater
good
Ness license through Washington 11 2027.
a video called the Alabama 2500 the
model
copy it should be an Elantra receipt
um
Anthony
foreign
Pennsylvania the where you go to find
law has been in Washington it's called
the revised code of Washington so I'll
try to turn my brightness up but
um it's basically it's just called an
RCW so it's RCW
46.61.202 so it's no driver shall enter
an intersection unless there is
significant space on the other side of
the intersection
[Music]
um to accommodate the vehicle he is
operating without obstructing the
passage of other vehicles despite any
traffic control signals signal
indications to proceed so you had a
green light so you're thinking you can
go but you're blocking the intersection
so that's um if you're ever curious and
any laws in Washington uh just Revise
Code of Washington
um so I'm not running a ticket or
anything like that today I understand
you're from Pennsylvania but in the
future don't proceed through the
intersection you can get stopped for
that alone unless you can clearly just
clear it right away so um so that
basically I understand you're just
supposed to wait behind the the white
line drivers do it all the time
um
wrong but I yeah well except for the
fact that I was blocking the crosswalk
which is yeah and States vary a lot of
from laws like Pennsylvania might not
even have that law but in Washington we
do I I'm actually just from a very rural
area so we just don't have crosswalks oh
unless I visit an area where there are
cross tracks it's
yeah I do apologize if I was
too many questions about the law I
wasn't trying to like no no no not at
all like I understand you're not from
here so
um if you don't a lot of people don't
know a bunch of laws like I only know it
because this is what I do but um yeah if
you're ever curious on any more laws
just RCW and they can be hard to read
because it's in like legal language but
um hope that helps yeah have a good day
definitely thanks